[Music]
like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is Wednesday
another guest today we have two guests
in a row and I think we're securing
another one on Friday today we have host
former Radio City Rockette podcaster TV
show star number bachelor contestant
Emmy winner what yes she was on The
Bachelor that's the funnest fact you
think the funniest act is that she's a
Rockette or that she wanted me it's that
she was on The Bachelor shut the [ __ ] up
I snuck in the day I think it was Brad
it was like one of the Brad's I'm sure I
know well in case you don't know not her
claim to fame no and if that didn't give
it away we have Kelsey Kelsey and I have
so many questions for her most likely
what it felt like being on Liz's
Instagram this yeah that's the biggest
line I'm so jealous I took so much to
talk to her about like how you turn your
podcast into a TV show like can I get
some notes yeah make sure you bring your
pen paper right and had a high kick
right okay and once you tell her that we
actually had some world-famous Radio
City Rockettes on our show who taught us
how to kick yeah and there's the day
still Sam they still said I can't
believe it's Wednesday its the best
skate like this week is just running
away from us you know what then I'm I'm
actually like it's crazy I'm a little
anxious about it there's something to be
said about a four-day workweek you know
I know we've gotten on our soapbox I'm
preached about it before but but we
haven't picked up our hour and I Ohio
like there's something so wonderful
about I just feel like the whole world
is like so concerned with work-life
balance I like the answers right in
front of us
four-day workweek three-day weekend
we're balanced than five to two it makes
so much more sense like I feel like this
is gonna be a really productive week for
me and I only had four days
no like yesterday I did more work you
were firing off emails I woke up from a
nap 69 emails just shooting up emails
because like almost half the week was
gone and I had to do half a week's worth
of work which just really goes back to
productivity and like I mean we are here
at the morning toast the problem with
workplace chrono ticket productivity
because it's like if you were just
productive all of the hours that you're
at work like you would need to work like
but the state wouldn't even need they
would need less people working but like
you know the jobs in the world like
there is no job that is meant to be 40
straight hours a week of like hard work
doctors yeah
lawyers ok real trade my bet OSI lawyer
drama was actually crazy actually got
bad for Gina I said I feel so badly for
Gina like watching her and Shannon come
together like it actually made me I felt
a lot of different ways but ultimately I
just felt really glad to be watching it
michio and you know what else I felt
really um supportive of gene I meet you
it but you know what else I felt I felt
that jealousy is not a good look on
Emily no I mean Emily's falling apart
thing is a good look on Emily that
moment where she her husband came home
from the bar like that was one of the
saddest moments of my life
like I've never felt so sad for someone
in my life I know and honestly I hope he
doesn't pass no I hope doesn't deserve
to I only want that things for him and I
feel like at this point because this was
filmed like a year ago
I'm expecting a divorce announcement
like yeah first of all its peace so open
like with the TV show about how your
marriage is falling apart you only do
that when your marriage is over like
when you're trying to keep it together
like for the kids you don't talk about
it on TV also I feel as though while
they're filming like these scenes
they're trying to keep together while
she's filming her testimonials which are
a few months later it might be over
because her testimonials are more
defeatist yeah scenes where she's like
still trying to be an optimist also they
gave him testimonials and he looked much
more handsome and he just wanted to show
what a monster he is did you miss your
wife oh my god awful awful evil ok so we
will recap Real Housewives of Orange
County
after the Fast Five today's supposed to
be dear toasters but because we just
have such a busy day between recaps we
have the snapshot I mean of Kelty we're
gonna save that for tomorrow when I
don't believe we have a guest and if
you're looking for a bachelor recap wait
a few hours the snatcher will be up on
the statuary the podcast page in a few
hours
yes so just you know the world keeps
turning we actually have some decent
news today okay um and I'm excited I'm
excited to chat about it here on the
morning toast
so what guys it's your first time here
yeah you know I've heard really great
things and my friends are in the group
and like they love it oh by the way I
was also super productive yesterday I
let in like almost a thousand people to
the morning toasters Facebook oh you did
that so yes i letting like 480 really
done that yes oh my god no and i but in
so many and people were just like really
i think this group of people that i let
let in were people who have been waiting
for a really long time because they put
so much effort into their answers i got
i was laughing at jokes I don't even
remember that we have no I know that's
my favorite part is like
see what inside jokes like are
established in the community but that we
didn't even realize our jokes right you
know who you know who didn't get in is
the girl who wrote you know how much
more of a Claudia because I talk over
people that I have no respect I bet you
didn't damn
but when you're doing membership and
like it's the third question for if you
want to get to the group is are you a
claw teairra Jackie or explain do you
tend to favor like the people who say
Jackie no because I don't want to seem
like you only get in if you said like
I'm it's like I'm so completely its
balance because I definitely favor the
people who say Claudia I'm like I don't
even need to know the reason check it
definitely isn't yes hard when someone
says Jackie and like yeah it makes me
feel good but in general I feel like
this duty to be super unbiased so I
probably give more to you you know wow I
guess you do something stubborn the
amount of your bias in the members of
Claudia's is so scary like we definitely
need Jackie's to balance the group yeah
that's your anyone someone says they're
a snitch and and and with someone's head
Sarah Theo or Olivia Olivia is that
means you know they have their head on
right yeah a hundred percent
um I know that's like super and
uninteresting till I tell people about
your dreams but I just want to tell the
trust there's my dream because it was so
weird and and I know why I had it but I
would love to get like an analyst
station analysis I'd my dream meet you
you and Ben we're at a club and I was
with Kevin Federline like and I don't
even I feel like if kevin federline
before this dream like walked up to me
on the street like I literally wouldn't
know who he was like has such a not
memorable face or at a not memorable
career and he's like famous but not a
memorable wardrobe but in my dream he
was so cute like he was snatched and so
cute and him and I were like making out
and Ben was right in front I'm so weird
was he a snatcher he said actually yes
eros I know he was so gross and then I
like I literally I woke up the first
thing I did was like what does Kevin
Federline look like and at Google
pictures of him obviously remember I was
reading a story about him right before
bed so that's why of course is that a
story yes yes I boil the story it's big
news big news so without further ado
should we get into the big news okay Wow
I'm fighting a cult I feel like that
went straight to your like brain yeah I
have a head high now oh yeah without
further ado here are the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up
a bite out of your morning toast that's
true
that's simply sure there's nothing you
just said that wasn't true but and I'm
gonna let you get there sis I'm gonna
let you get there you're gonna let me
finish I'm gonna let you finish but I do
need to let everyone know that stays
episode is brought to you by function of
beauty love it we honor the frustration
bottles and bottles piling up in your
bathroom each one falsely promising a
miracle solution that only kind of work
but what if there was just one shampoo
that could truly do it all functions of
beauty is a hair care brand that has a
quiz so that's how you know it's premium
as [ __ ] they ask you ton of questions
about what type of hair you have what
you're looking to get out of your hair -
I kind of broken and looking for like
some hydration also I don't like a
fragrance in my shampoo because it like
stains my pillows and I just don't like
it
I love a fragrance so you can choose
like not fragrance today in my pillow
or you can choose a type of fragrance
it's just super customized and then they
could use huge bottles like [ __ ]
little shampoo I bought like a I got my
hair cut and I bought like the fancy
shampoo they trying to upsell you and it
was like literally three days worth of
shampoo like I have a ton of hair I
don't need just a dollop I need it's
like a puddle I'm so the function of
beauty ones are enormous bottles that's
just the better that's one of the the
most premium parts of it they trust all
your hair needs not just one because
most Trumpster brands only address a
single concern like they volumizer they
strengthen but with function of beauty
you can choose up to five hair goals to
add to your formulation they have
unrivaled customization with that over
54 trillion combinations possible
function of beauty individually
formulates every bottle based on your
hair type your hair goals and your
preferences they never use sulfates
parabens flatulates if you can't
pronounce it it shouldn't be in there
mineral oils are any harmful ingredients
they're safe and natural it is vegan and
cruelty-free and it's the internet's
top-rated customer haircare brand i
really enjoy using it also they put my
name on the bottle which just like makes
me feel special yeah and if you want to
get in on all the fun
listeners can receive 20% off your first
order to redeem head to function of
beauty.com slash toast
take the hair profile quiz go to
function of beauty calm slash toast to
get 20% off in your custom formula and i
am i i've been getting a lot of
compliments on my hair recently mostly
from the toasters and I've been using
function of beauty and I don't think
that it's unrelated no I don't I don't
detract I think it's relating because
before function of beauty I was just
using like whatever shampoo and
conditioner like Zack uses so like mezzo
or drugstore yeah I never put thought
into my shampoo
I just felt like a big tub from like I
buy like unisex like you know I need my
I'm a fancy lady I need my own and
function beauties to the rescue wait I
have to share some super interesting
information because I was just gonna ask
you are you wearing k'kaw shimmer on
your legs
yeah they look shiniest I've only
investor County but I wanted to share a
very piece of interesting piece of
information that I got an email
yesterday hmm I got a PR gifting from
Skinz
oh I got it last week whatever I'm so
[ __ ] exactly was so excited mostly
because I really need and I didn't think
I was gonna be able to get her because
her [ __ ] is always selling out like
that's why I'm excited like this is a
necessity like they asked for sizes in
everything no I know and I usually does
that mean they're sending everything
usually would like a PR company since
like send me ur sizes like you know I
totally lie like I don't need my real
sizes I ask for my brows I gave it just
straight up and this time I was
incredibly honest just because I
actually want to use this stuff like
with PR so I'm like yeah what size eight
yeah I'm a size four shoe ya know I'm
really excited I think we should do an
episode just Justin's
okay yeah I could do that bring it to
show them how grateful we are and how
committed we are the opportunity love it
and how is a great choice for them to
Santas did you tell you the fast facts I
said it um so let's get into it yeah you
said it let's do it
without further ado first story former
Disney Channel star Jordan Pruitt claims
she was treated like a quote cash cow in
sex abuse lawsuit okay I'm gonna go
through the details and then I want your
thoughts
I read the podcast reviews yesterday and
they begged me to stop singing and I
will accept for you make me wanna jump
to the rhythm and dance to the music all
in together will show how we do it
during person icon that's the only thing
like that it's actually enjoyable but
it's but you know you're in a middle of
a sentence and you just like hit a high
note it's just as sad people just don't
value your talent anymore like I think
there are audio constraints in the
podcast show and that's one of them
let's watch the Kelty about it Jordan
Pruitt isn't staying silent anymore the
former Disney Channel star in the voice
contestant broke her silence on Tuesday
afternoon after alleging that she had
been sexually abused by her former
manager Keith Thomas and she's naming
names yeah apparently she filed the suit
like we
go under Jane Doe yeah and now she's
coming out according according to legal
documents filed on August 14th and
obtained by E news the 20 year old
singer/songwriter filed a lawsuit
against Thomas and her former record
label record label Hollywood Records and
its parent company Walt Disney she filed
a lawsuit on seven counts including
sexual battery of a minor intentional
infliction of emotional distress
negligence negligent supervision
negligent retention / hiring negligent
failure to warn train or educate and
breach of fiduciary duty sounds like a
lot of negligence
moreover Pruitt claimed Hollywood
Records and Walt Disney Company both
failed to prevent the abuse which she
alleges began when she was 14 years old
and continued until a week before she
turned 16
right the lawsuit states that he was
like a known abuser and if he and if he
wasn't known by some people like the
negligence allowed for it yeah 100% and
like if this goes all the way to the top
she's calling everyone out I'm shedding
you're so proud of her because I this is
obviously so hard to do so few people
are doing it in public way naming names
and like she's laying it all out there
this is so brave like I really hope
there were like when you finally like
come out and sit and do something like
you've been afraid to do like people are
so [ __ ] nasty like I don't even want
to know what people are saying about her
on Twitter so I hope she's not reading
that because what she did was very brave
and I'm sure it took her a long time to
get there yeah
I haven't seen anything I see but I also
like don't for nasty sad and you also
don't have Twitter that's true I do on
the toes you know every now and then I
got a notification like the morning
toast like you're sweet and I'm like I
know that's Jackie or say anymore go I
don't it could be an accident I don't
know how to use Twitter but I'm always
on the toast Twitter are you looking at
like hat like Bachelor Paradise stuff
yeah I'm always on the toaster like that
I use that as my personal Twitter yeah
like Twitter sucks but it's a necessary
evil it is I don't know what the
necessity is no me neither but it's just
fun yeah but then even like I guess the
necessity say is like who I putting
bachelor in paradise scene what people
think but like then I read it I'm like
oh that's not what I think no that's not
the necessity for me I actually make my
own or later I didn't think that the
Matt Donald montage was like the best 20
seconds of television show oh my god and
I just thought like every this this
particular week was like too boring
episodes and like Twitter was I trying
to make fetch happen like I mean like
bachelor in paradise from who I follow
their account was like between every
single person who was like
kissing montage like it wasn't funny no
he's like it was Kido but like is it
worth of 1,000 retweets I don't think
anything not like they just went on a
date the fact like they're kissing isn't
a huge deal no that's what's so
disgusting about this show it's like the
premise is like he's a freak because he
doesn't want to kiss someone he's known
for a day like he's mommy's watching I
totally I totally agree he's a nice guy
yeah
and the sweating thing so relatable
tyronn totally did he chose one left too
early because Matt Donnell was the man
for her yeah I'm obsessed with Bree
she's a body Instagram no but her like
on the good news leaderboard
like are you her Instagram is so premium
like her pictures are so great plus
she's like a model so she knows how to
she models for Morgan Stewart yeah and
like a bunch of websites I'm always
seeing her on website no I know like
it's I was really excited about her and
I'm annoyed that she didn't get to come
sooner and like wasn't given the respect
that she deserves because there's no one
on the beach were heard of on the day
web she was literally gonna go she might
be the last person to come which like
usually that person gives up their Day
card to a couple who needs a date right
like let's say before the snaps are okay
see ya anyways so proud of Jordan Pruitt
we stand behind here we are with her
we are totally with herbed in the right
direction of the take town of the
pedophilia ring that is Hollywood yes
definitely like we need to be protecting
our children they are the future if
we're not protecting them if we're not
protecting that who are we protecting
right our adult self so you can protect
ourselves Larry nesters of the world no
thank you
no the children do it for the children
speaking of the children Britney Spears
is ex-husband Kevin Federline receives
more custody of the couple's children I
feel like I can't really give like a an
impartial you know take on this story
yeah with him last night me and like
Kevin are like an item yeah Britney
Susan Kevin Federline are adjusting
their Kyle child custody arrangement
according to court documents obtained by
E news the former couple has agreed that
Kevin will get custody of their two boys
70% of the time as for Britney she will
get 30% unsupervised custodial rights
previously the duo agreed on 50/50
custody this new arrangement reportedly
has been in place since August 2018
things became official however last week
so it's not a huge deal that this is
happening cuz it's been this way for a
while
I'm not formally but now it's formal
also he like filed a report
that Britney Spears is dad-like abused
one of the boys well it's very confusing
because I didn't know that the dad's
name is Jamie Eddie and they kept
referring to Jamie's fears in this
article and like jeez here's did not do
that like there's no way jamie-lynns da
we shouldn't do it so he was very
confusing and then I realized he was the
dad and it was like a little wishy-washy
about what happened but like the kids
were at the dad's house and one of the
kids did something bad and I guess the
dad like overreacted and Kevin Federline
was very upset about it they said he had
no visible bruises or anything but he
like scared the kid yeah not cool not
cool like grandparents like I understand
sometimes children need to be
disciplined like grandparents are
supposed to be like this people give the
chocolate and yeah those little
strawberry candies and just your job a
hundred percent
I'm very interesting that I never really
think of like Britney Spears and Kevin
Federline like as a co-parenting unit
anymore like I legitimately forgot that
they were the kid's dad so this was just
like a crazy reminder for me and I don't
know why I'm like getting the feeling
like Kevin Federline's like a good dad I
was just gonna say like I think that he
might be because one Britney let him
have more custody of the children like
before I've been taking to the courts
which is just like he must be usually
great you have to like fight to take
someone's children away for more time
like you have to like fight two
especially from a mother like a mother
the court always favors the mom in
custody right but like we all know
Britney has a lot going on right now
like it seems that Kevin is there for
her there for the kids I don't know but
that I'm also watching big little lies
where like the grandmas trying to take
up the kids away from select wait
Chuckie sorry No third you said or third
it's still not going on okay anyway so
I'm just like seeing it through that
what is it like it's not it's not like a
kind yeah because she didn't tell you
how did so in Kevin Federline like I see
she's still on tour with the Backstreet
Boys
to see a pink um he's not a Backstreet
Boy I don't think he ever was he is no
he's not he's not Kevin from watching
boys wait so who the [ __ ] wait he's just
a dancer like at one of her no yes no no
wait um like my whole world is falling
apart what like Britney Spears Merida
back whew boy
but she I thought but 1000% she did no
Kevin wait my head life is absolutely
made I would that he's got him in a
Backstreet Boy no you made up with a
backup dancer who the [ __ ] is Kevin
Federline a dancer he's not a singer No
I think he was one of her backup dancers
that's how they met he is a rapper DJ
actor television personality
professional wrestler and model okay so
one of those things yeah that's what he
became like after becoming Britney's
wasn't don't know like how shocked I am
that he's not about to look like a
picture of Kevin from Backstreet Boys
they're not the same person Kevin from
Max wars is way cuter yeah oh he's got a
Chiba okay I just want to say wow I'm so
shocked I thought this was Kevin
Federline
you know I've never you made out this
was my dream oh so that's your yes so
who the [ __ ] is Kevin Federline that's
the big question he doesn't see the job
like his job is like Britney Spears's
husband like he was doing to get spousal
support yes yeah yes and I think now he
gets a child support child support and
he's a good dad so now he's like Kevin
Federline dad dad to the stars
yeah wait I'm like so shocked like for
my whole life I thought Kevin from the
Backstreet Boys just Kevin Federline so
you some pretty nice fears married about
you boy yeah what wonderful world were
you totally I'm like and that would mean
such a big trail to Justin I'm feeling
like really shaken up like so what did
you think happened like she went from
NSYNC
to Backstreet Boys and do you think
that's where the feud started no I mean
I just don't I was so young back then I
don't remember like the intricacies of
all the relationships I just remember
like you know they wore denim Kevin yeah
it was a Britney I'm like I'm shaking
like I'm really like my whole life is a
lie am I the only person I thought this
yeah the comments like Kevin like no
offense Kevin like I'm sure you've been
doing great things recently but like he
was a true no one like a nobody
so like you were lying or Backstreet Boy
so you weren't expected to know who he
was
other than Britney Spears as husband but
didn't you date a bunch of people no
maybe post right
oh my god I'm I don't know how I can
like finish this show like my whole life
is gonna lie what a fun lie like to
think that the Queen of Pop and a court
jester of pop got together Wow
that's all that's literally all I have
to say as well I'm like I'm [ __ ] I'm
speech this is a new level of memory
loss yes it is says Chloe same reason to
go to some sort of like therapy for my
brain discussion err
okay next story a spot of news at a
Fidel's camp all right adele is quote
perky as hell okay like it
I relate I think she's actually good
after difficult divorce and itching to
share music with fans so it's not in the
news often now she's on the cover of
People magazine with sources saying
stuff but she's like the cover of People
magazine like not my choice right she
didn't do a photo shoot for them I don't
know like doubt it it's not not by
choice People magazine is like a weird
publication where it's like it's looped
in with like the trash like okay
magazine US magazine like tabloids that
you read in the airports but it actually
it's like kind of a respectable tabloid
a lot of people like give their like
exclusives to them and they have like
articles about firefighters who are
heroes like they have a lot of human
interest pieces
I feel like Oprah like respects the hell
out of people I think they're trying to
come out of like the airport tabloid
yeah anything they're doing an okay job
it looks like this picture every day
looks like from an award ceremony but I
don't think they just put Adele on the
cover with nonsense when they have like
a ton of other exclusive stories they
could do so I have to believe there's a
spot of truth to this they had the Kevin
and Astrid exclusive they did we got all
the bachelor exclusives yeah I'm really
happy for them oh my god they're just
like normal as she always says Adele is
channeling her heartache into music
multiple sources tell people the
superstar who announced her separation
from her longtime love in the spring is
ready to release new songs sooner than
later quote she's definitely getting
ready both mentally and physically to
promote new music it seems it will
happen later this year says one source
close to the 31 year old singer quote
she talked about last year as a very
difficult year and she said in the past
that creating new music is almost like
therapy you can tell that she is ready
to share with her fans on her previous
albums 19 21 and 25 the Grammy winner
poured her heart into her art and a
music industry source says Adele's
upcoming work will be just as personnel
there's so many types of divorces and I
just have a feeling that this Adele one
is gonna be one where it's like not
messy so genuine love and respect for
each other but like we both just moved
on and she can like write really like
good happy and sad music about it you
know yes yes sad about the loss excited
about the future yeah I agree I feel
like I don't know but I just wanted a
happy Adele I know and I feel like she
was so happy so to affirm so happy to
not be Matt that person it's like it has
to have been devastated
and whoever was the inspiration behind
someone like you which I assuming is the
guy before her husband yeah like a
million guys ago right
like what did he do to her I don't know
no no so I hope I mean selfishly like I
hope this guy this husband like really
hurt her so we can get like another
someone like you yeah yeah listen my
girl Adele I don't her going through any
pain so so tough we will get it before
the end of the year I feel like she
loves a winter moment you know - she
doesn't come out with me music in the
summer there are like four or five
artists who I think are incredibly
strategic about when they released their
music so as not to compete with one
another like I think in terms of album
sales the only people who really compete
are like Taylor Beyonce Adele in terms
of sales and like they want to own the
record and own the moment so we just got
a Taylor album so it could mean like in
the next four or five months we could
get a better tell album I think once the
the time has passed and lover is oh this
yeah I'm ready like I feel ready I feel
like we we have a lot of great music out
there but not really balanced no I think
about and flat I need uh-huh I'm telling
you Ben pot is amazing amazing and it's
new song this amazing amazing stuff he
can't fat he's really carved out like a
genre for himself that I don't even know
what to call it he's really the next
Josh Groban yeah but like pop Josh
Groban Josh Groban pass Groban no it's
like he can do whatever he wants he has
his fans and he's playing to them you
know he's not trying to be something
that he's not no not at all it's like we
know that we like you do what you want
we support and like we don't want to
hear you try and be like a pop star like
we want to hear your voice yeah we'd
have been baggy pants yes JJ yeah we
want you to be every day shal Radio City
in September we gotta go gotta go oh for
sure um yeah Adele we're ready for you
Adele is just an icon that hair you had
face that eyeliner is letting Loki like
she lives the best life like she's so
famous she's so right smell like she's
so low toilet and pride it but then she
also like gets to hang out with everyone
she was like really cool friends I think
she has a great personality and everyone
wants to be around her I think so too
they're always having a good time we
always have the best time yeah and I
just feel like she gets the best of all
world yeah and I think a lot of that has
to do with living in London like I think
they
they respect people's privacy London
like it's not as barbaric as it is in
America so much she wants to like get
paparazzi and be like a girly girl she
can go to New York
yeah like selectively that sounds so fun
yeah I think it's my tailor also spends
a ton of time in London I've never see
photos of her in London I feel like he
lives says a lot about them like when a
celebrity's main like home is in New
York they're like more down-to-earth I'm
like low-key London the same like when
they live in LA like you just know that
they're like a thirst monster like
mainly living in LA
yeah they're mainly thirsting get out
there cuz they just got to be in town in
case there's any thirsty events
happening right where they can go get
their photo taken and like hold up but
like a beverage right and like also they
put their house on the starmap walk of
fame whatever it's called totally okay
next story another bit of good news but
remember tour guide so yes it is a lip
liner that I got in my Birchbox ooh I'm
loving Birch Bayh this is Birchbox way
before they partnered with the toasts
but now that they are it is like truly
just gifts like I always forget that
it's gonna come and then a month comes
and I got this hair serum because I have
really bad flyaways and it makes my hair
not oily but shiny and then like really
tucks away all my broken hairs um it's
just like it's a present to yourself it
really is and like you deserve it and
once a month like you should be like so
excited for school and you should be
trying new beauty products because like
sometimes the routines get stale you
gotta spice it up and that you don't
spend a lot of money on a huge item
before you know if you like it so they
all burped Birchbox is like a monthly
subscription that sends you smaller
sizes of products that they think you're
like from hair to makeup beauty wellness
skin and then if you like it you can buy
the full thing on your own but you just
never know and like I hate spending
money on something and they have this
huge tub of moisture so that I don't
even like yeah and sometimes I just want
to try something right but I can't try
it in a store no and then those little
travel sizes are great for travel yeah
it's so fun and it's also super useful
and I think it's super toasty and you
guys should get on the Birchbox train
the fact is shopping for fun stuff like
beauty products isn't always so fun
you're either scrolling to a website
where you can't even get a feel for the
product are you being approached by a
million salespeople when you're just
trying to find a nice tester that's why
we love Birchbox it's a new way to buy
beauty they make it easy and convenient
and fun to discover new products and buy
full-size versions of the samples when
you are done and you can also earn
loyalty points while you're at it the
samples and surprises are delivered to
your door it's a fun treat every month
and you can really
experience of products with deluxe and
travel sized samples it's not just those
single-use packets like you get into
store Birchbox is an accessible way to
discover and enjoy beauty products and
it's great for everyone even with the
uninitiated busy and busiest among us
Birchbox lot works with over 500
prestige brands and offers something for
every hair type skin concern and
lifestyle yes have you open the box you
think you're gonna get a bunch of like
no-name products like no I could sell
you from bliss like rich the same
products curated for you ones that you
love head over to Bertie Botts calm
slash TMT to get started at Birchbox and
get five dollars off when you use promo
code TNT so the code is TMT and the
website is Birchbox comm / TMT for five
dollars off your first purchase box also
it makes a great gift Margo told me
didn't your friends get you like a year
subscription to Birchbox
yeah when you moved into your first
apartment yeah that's such a nice it was
OU's actually super exciting I found my
eyeliner that way right so code TMT
website Birchbox comm / TMT yes that's
one of the bands I'm really excited
about - and one that I knew about before
cuz they're like fancy and like they're
like a billion dollar company totally ok
next story is definitely bittersweet
because it's happy news for Jonah Hill
and his fiance but it's sad nervously
justice for Ruthie and by the way the
timing this really could have been
Ruth's eggs
ya know I know like when he was on Emel
explaining Ruthie in a second when he
was on those apps like he was looking
for his white wife and he found her so
um about a year ago maybe two years ago
it was the craziest day and the toasters
Facebook group so a girl a toaster named
Dorothy named Ruthie match and was
messaging with Jonah Hill from the DMing
no I think it was dating he was courting
her he like weren't interested in her
she was really pretty she just a cute
like she was so into it obviously she's
a toaster she's talking about in the
group like she was how asking for help
on like what to say like when you say to
a movie star she was so excited and
[ __ ] snitch and not this one then
never remember I'm such a rapid of rat
message Jonah and told him that the girl
that he was talking she was I talking
about it in a Facebook group and like in
a negative way but it wasn't even
negative it wasn't negative at all she
was just like excited and wanted help to
talk to a movie star it was the craziest
day where they orgy ening
oh that's even like crazy GIM Chi Minh
was like - to see you on the street like
ogre meet-cute yeah it was like so he
was like yeah and it was like you wanna
get lunch or something like it was so
[ __ ] cute and like perfect like
that's how you should meet a movie star
and some [ __ ] snitch drilled it and
he like totally had it what did he say
he was just like.he like gold in her and
moved on yeah a little over a year ago
like the amount of time that you did
someone before you get engaged like this
Chiana could have been Ruthie and we
could have had them on the toast right
now I'm talking about their engagement
and we could have been invited to the
wedding
I'm so upset like that was the hardest
day that was the hard to say now I'll
never forget I think that's like
probably the biggest the biggest
disappointment to come out of the
toasters group there's been so many same
clothes as well but that was probably
like most negative every guy comes alone
right Jonah Hill and his girlfriend not
Ruthie but Gianna Santos are engaged to
be married
page six has exclusively learned pals of
the outer director have been buzzing
about the happy news and a rep confirmed
the engagement to not Ruthie on Tuesday
he'll 35 and not 30 reportedly began
dating last summer right after he broke
up with a woman worth a over DM so much
she's the Content Manager at a beauty
start up violet gray according to yeah
just like Ruthie was with obviously head
stylist and producer I'd hit fashion
brand kids very cool still not she's a
cool girl she graduated from Fordham in
2011 while they went deep into her
Lincolnton that's the only public page
that she has obviously I'm Monday the
couple were spotted in Manhattan heading
out of the Crosby Street hotel to
breakfast at the smile though photos of
the smiling duo walking in the rain
didn't seem to show her ring ring maybe
because he was saving the Rings
Variety reported this week that help
just plunked down six point seven seven
million dollars for a thirty one hundred
square foot home in Santa Monica
California that roof he could have been
living in oh my god well I'm happy for
him he's like so weird like I can't
believe he's beneath help Singh's
brother you know hey by the way everyone
keeps saying that but then I saw a
picture of her for book-smart like on my
TV and she was just like him it was
gonna fail no they're both like just
like so Jewish okay there's they have
the same look but then they're also have
the same face interesting like they're
it's why don't they have the same name I
don't know
I like good for both of them
all right they don't know hardly know
hail could have become like a true movie
star been in wolf awhile sheet with the
name Jonah Feldstein I actually think it
would have been fine like that's his
brand are they full like blood relation
clearance or yeah which is why they have
really choice but like to us we'll just
take any connection it to us it's all
the same [ __ ] yeah and it's like wilt
like we're just striving for those
connections like to meet gigi hadid in
kendall Jenner our sisters they once
shared the same stepfather who was
married to a stepmother yeah
the counts it counts yeah well happy for
Jonah Hill and not Ruthie I hope they
have a very happy life together
but I hope Jonah knows like if if any
you know time comes where he's doubting
or thinking about Ruthie it's never too
late it's never too late no and like
Ruthie if you're out there like I'm
sorry for the hard news like I know you
she was invested in know this I'm by the
way I'm taking this news hard I can only
imagine how hard with he's taking the
news like it's like she's like she's
seeing Gianna like lived the life she
was supposed to live in Santa Monica
like it's not a million dollar house and
like Ruthie is totally Jewish name
Gianna I don't know I don't know how
they could have made like perfect Jewish
babies yeah you know the old Jewish lady
inside me is she's up and I hope that
speech wherever you are I think we found
her she shows again with the snitch was
yeah but that is insane and like I don't
want to jinx anything but here I go
we haven't had a case of some joke -
should you say but if I say it it
doesn't no say it happens no it's always
the thing that you don't expect like
your pictures not showing up in the
Rascal Flatts meet-and-greet but they
did show up but they get up to a few
mysteries episode we found our meeting
three pictures of Rascal Flatts and
they're so ugly but so precious yeah
they're so ugly but so cute they could
have like it's also better lighting but
whatever yeah I don't think those are
the things rascal cares about okay
our fifth and final story before we cap
Real Housewives of Orange County it's
just something I feel so excited and so
passionate about because hallmarks 2019
Christmas movie slate is here what what
time of year do they start putting them
out September countdown to Christmas oh
it looks like in October so today's a
good time yeah that is a good Halloween
movies yes they do everything a seasonal
yeah you know also September it's like
way too soon it's still 70 degrees in
you are gonna want to watch your
Christmas movie no and they have to do
like autumnal movies falling in love
yeah like
and like the fall parade yeah yeah the
pumpkin carving when there's when it's
time to start I probably won't start
participating until November I really
want to watch falling in love I just
like I was about to watch it before
about last night but I was so tired and
I really wanted to enjoy it and it looks
so good I'd die for Christina Milian so
I'm gonna save it for like a weekend
moment yeah definitely it's definitely
like a Saturday afternoon
yeah so we have a lot of movies the
schedule has come out and a lot of names
that that I don't know what about it
Alicia May what's her name
Oh alicia witt Toaster alicia witt I
forgot to tell you I mean I know you
don't watch the final season tomorrow
just a new black but she's in it oh
she's perfect she's really movin on up
here's an interesting fact of it on
factoid on November 24th Christmas at
Graceland is premiering with Adrian
Grenier is already movie create a crease
on home for the holidays it must be
sequel must have done really well we and
Priscilla Presley is in it
Oh is there any what's her name the girl
that I love in the one from Miss
Christmas Oh Brooke something Brooke
d'Orsay yes no I'm telling you like so
about little wieners I'm oh she's in
Christmas in Rome sounds like a winner
uh-oh Kristin Chenoweth is in Hallmark
Hall of Fame and Christmas love stories
Wow Danica McKellar Danica McKellar is
in Christmas at Dollywood
that's Dolly Parton's in it oh there's
some big names also Chad Michael Murray
he's honestly so homesick he's on the up
and up in a movie called right before
Christmas wow this is so exciting
they're really pulling out all the big
budgets Kepler is in a film called the
mistletoe secret we talked about Kellie
Pickler for a minute I think like she's
goals do you yes she like is living the
dream like she's a celebrity she's in
hallmark movies she has a morning show
on hallmark I believe it got canceled oh
no it was on CMT it was Pickler men he
was on CMT it was canceled well she had
an opportunity for more each on CMT
which sounds like the dream there'll be
a couple on the show so yeah she was
playing her cello yeah it sounds like
the dream so if she squandered her own
dream fine but at least she that her
dream came true it does like her
drinking Barrett lots of fruitful money
oh I don't know but then I think she
does like Instagram ads right so she
does all of it Elizabeth Smart does
Instagram ads I know
talk about that on the show last week
and upon further investigation we found
out that she does talk up that bit
button box every now and then here are
some exciting factoids a Merry Christmas
match showering Ashley new bro
I don't know if you remember her but she
was in privileged with Lucy Hale she
played the sister
oh that looks like Khloe Kardashian yes
oh man I'm sure bleach was the best one
season on CW starring Joanna Garcia
Swisher Lucy Hale and Khloe Kardashian
this is the best show it was the best
show I recently watched you see the CW
seed it's like all their throwback shows
and it was so incredible but then it
ended abruptly because like they were
able to do and I was just like it really
shook me it was such a good show
I recommend binge watching it on CW see
because it's so if I can go but then
you'll fall into a depression because
it's only one season and you don't get
to know justice it's Joanna Garcia
Switzer she is amazing selection when it
comes to like movies and TV shows and
they're so good and they like never work
out yes but she's - is living the dream
yeah well she's married to Nick Swisher
and Ben Ben tells me he's quite wealthy
and they are just the toast of the town
yeah so I feel like she gets to work
when she wants to like best friends with
Leah Michelle yes she gets to take
whatever role that she wants but there's
like no pressure and she's so beautiful
and she seems really fun and happy and
like she just has like cool friends -
that's it that's everything yeah Brooke
d'Orsay is in nostalgic Christmas with
Trevor Donovan from 90210 teddy god yeah
I and Rachael Leigh Cook from she's all
that is in a Blue Ridge Mountain
Christmas on November 7th happy thank
you very it's big celebrities who like
lend their name and likeness to hallmark
movies they do it because they get paid
a lot or because it's such a big
platform like so many people all around
the world watch Hallmark there like it's
almost like a great PR move I think it's
the platform I think they get paid money
is money and then it's like they tell
them 60 million homes are turning into
Hallmark Christmas countdown right and
it's like that's a kind of demographic
you can't get on Instagram Oh big time
Alicia oh it will be starring in our
Christmas love song November 21st Jesse
Metcalfe and autumn Reeser oh in
Christmas under the
start Jesse Blake Shelton in time for
you to come home for Christmas is he
gonna saying I don't know Ashley green
love her she's perfect
she is perfect in an unforgettable
Christmas on December 19th you guys he
played Alice in Twilight it's like we're
like people who had hit TV shows back in
the day just go to go to get work yeah
yeah it's single-handedly keeping like a
third of Hollywood in yeah like Candace
Cameron Bure yep I think she must do
really well yeah she's not my favorite
maybe the middle and and either any of
the whole I guess I just don't my full
house but not like Jodie Sweetin none of
those kids I don't like any of them
unless they're getting Mary Kate and
Ashley like nice this is the first
hallmark with a Lori Loughlin honestly
they stacked up they didn't act up they
had to make up for the loss yeah but you
know who's not here at Jesco roundest
where is she
oh I never like she is the most
beautiful grind with her she is from now
that you know she played Audrey honoré
yeah beautiful it really just it's so
filigree shallow but the movies really
depend on the beauty of the characters
like it stage it's so true because the
plots pretty thin like no matter what
it's always the same type of plot so
it's watching beautiful people is always
enjoyable yeah and like when sometimes I
really believe in the love it's like you
guys were hooking up on set like then
yeah and sometimes like now that they're
like big-budget fancy movie studios they
don't really do that but when we first
started watching they would only hire
actors who looked exactly like other
actors but like with a little something
different so you like wait is that
Jennifer Lawrence
yeah no no yes no no Sena performance
they now they have their real about of
their old model Kyle Massey is in a
merry christmas' match with Ashley new
bro I sneak how Richards and honestly I
feel the Chi Richards could do a shine
Ibiza her think she would be her but
she's starring do you see the news she's
coming out with the Chaney Lee Curtis
and like the Halloween sequel Nick the
movie that made her famous Oh doing like
every damn Halloween oh they're doing it
again and Kyle's in it very cool very
well
lots of industry news today they're also
doing when calls the heart Christmas
when calls the heart is Lori Loughlin
Stig yeah
not anymore well before we bring out Cal
Tate let's recap Real Housewives of
Orange County because it was actually a
fine episode it was better than last
week it's getting better very
interesting was the Lizzie and Gretchen
of it all yes like my heart was with
Bronwyn my heart was with Bronwyn until
she was just like such a [ __ ] and like
was crying like did you know why she
came into the group and everyone
immediately like turned she didn't think
she was gonna have to go up against and
it's obvious that she's not good at
confrontation and she couldn't hear she
would not handle it but it's like the
shoe the other shoe dropped real quick
for her yeah it was like the quickest
and weirdest fall from grace I've ever
seen ever and the like wasn't that weird
no I didn't you know so she made to
Orange County someone set her up with a
couple friends and she texts them I
think it was so weird I didn't think it
was weird either and like I guess she
was intentionally lying like if someone
reaches out to me or I reach out to them
because a friend said like you guys
should reach out like it's not a big
deal it doesn't matter reach out to him
because here nor there I agree that
Weber initiated conversations is
sometimes an important detail but when
it's a mutual friend like setting up a
couple friends it actually doesn't
matter and the text that she Sam was
like so benign and sweet like hey I'm
new in town like so-and-so said we
should meet and they're acting like
Bronwyn reached out to these girls to
get tea on the ladies and like stir [ __ ]
up no but no like it's not her fault
that that's who was recommended now I I
wanted to say something that might be a
little controversial but tamil regards
Lizzie and Gretchen is like evil you
can't talk to them if you're friends
with them you're not friends with me
they tried to take my husband down they
called him gay and yada yada yada but I
feel like on this franchise they have
said far worse things about each other
and it's like why is now this one
particular thing that Lizzie and
Gretchen did like so much worse than
like the Train thing you know what I
mean like right well it's saying that
Kelly does coke also um Vicki was the
one who started the rumor about Eddie so
like they were just and like people
she's friends with Vicki other people
are friends with Nicki she doesn't have
this like
no-fly zone with Nicki they were just
being like followers and you were trying
to stir [ __ ] up and also being just
thirst monsters I think Tamra just
doesn't like them yeah um and she's
forgiven Vicki because she has to
because they're co-workers like to her
like Lizzie and Gretchen are dead to her
and they're just like
persona non-grata Shannon I loved her
but she was so incredibly wrong to blame
the Train thing on Vicki like why is no
one talking about how literally Tamra
brought it up no Tamra but like Vicki
could have just said something that was
like [ __ ] up and like he makes you
think there's more but like we don't
know what that they always say that on
Housewives like I know more and they
never tell you but they always say like
if you do what I knew Tamra said the
word train for the first time she also
was the one explaining the rumor in the
car
and so if I was Kelly dad I would be
mostly mad at time what if she is and
and everyone was saying like Emily's
being nosy and uh Bronwyn is being a
liar telling Kelly like being a [ __ ]
star they're like okay they definitely
are doing that but why is literally
nobody talking about the elephant in
there like Tamra brought it up and made
it a storyline I just feel like no one
has real they haven't seen it back yet
and they don't realize that that's how
it went down and like that time they ate
I'm like they're covering for her
anything it's like sometimes when you
see it the way that we've seen it like
just spelled out for us they they still
think it's Vicki because they're all
saying that it's Vicki
yeah I'm Kelly's relationship with it's
kind of weird yeah I but now they're we
know they're not together which makes me
sad and like now I I don't look at their
conversations as cute even though I
thought he was giving her a good advice
me too
very much so like I want to be like oh
my god that's her man he's very loving
he's level-headed like everything he
said was correct I go be with your
daughter and like I like a guy who I can
hear something you know not so
flattering about a woman and neither be
like okay if that's true whatever and if
it's not sure whatever no he's very
mature like yeah which is a concept
completely lost on this group of people
no a hundred percent it's really
refreshing to see I just wish I knew
that it was true up I know I'm sorry my
getting engaged the eight carrot soup I
can't I was on my phone a lot during the
episode and that the scene was one of
them yeah it was um it's not the most
interesting season so far the dynamics
are shifting and I think everyone's
trying to figure out where Bronwyn fits
and where Vicki fits not being a
full-time housewife like everyone seems
confused and so many of the ladies lives
are truly falling apart at the seams
that like they don't have time to to
give the show any attention like Jeana
deliver there was sheriff's showing up
to her house trying to arrest her and
Emily can't get her husband her life
depended on it
my struggle and I think I say this every
week but it's still the struggle I'm
having is like we are expected to care
about the disintegrating lives of women
who we never got to know we just met
like I am this week I really wanted to
like care and be there
Gina but I'm like your life started
falling apart so you went on a TV show
and now like we all need to support you
but like we don't know you
when Shannon was going through it that
was after seasons of just like watching
them go to therapy Aries girl I'm like
her trying and like we just got to know
her and like that's why we all rally
behind her and I feel that way about
Gina but now that she's being like super
open like I just I feel like she's super
relatable and like a lot of people can
get with her but with Emily I'm just
like who what where when why it's just
painful to watch like it's painful to
watch like a person that I don't know a
relationship I don't understand and try
and like form opinions on it I honestly
don't [ __ ] know next week I believe
the dancing in Vegas comes to a grand
finale and I don't think I can watch it
it's too sad it's so sad but it
shouldn't be like I just I don't I I
don't really I just don't really yeah I
feel like it also I think Emily's
hesitation with ever like getting
divorces I think she like really loves
his in-laws yeah but then the mom was
not being motherly I don't think she was
happy about Emily saying the stuff on
camera about her son yeah and it was a
little too matter-of-fact you know like
sometimes when you're like sharing or
opening up like it's something you
didn't expect to do like this she's very
[Music]
like obvious about everything because
she's like a lawyer a smart woman but
where are the emotions I taught - matter
of fact well I think their relationship
and their marriage was always a matter
of fact thing like they got engaged on
gchat but like how do you have that sort
of relationship for ten years like that
is such a long time I don't you know no
I then and then you wake up one day and
it's just like this or was it like this
the whole time oh no you know like Gina
there's like she loves her husband
there's an affair right he understand
there was a timeline yeah I just don't
understand even the good parts of this
relationship and that's why I'm just
saying what are we doing I don't I don't
know if there are good parts of the
relationship the kids I guess yeah the
kids are really really cute yeah it's
just it's really sad yeah I just I I
feel badly for her I I just don't know
what advice to give her don't either
no not at all and does he have a job
he's trying to be a lawyer but it wasn't
he her boss so how did she become an
attorney and he do and he didn't what
was nice was like a head enter or
something
maybe he was like head of hiring that's
a good call you know like I thought he
was her superior for so long right maybe
they weren't working in law I don't know
I don't that truly boring episode but
yeah the legal stuff you know it it
always makes me wonder like what I said
when I read it in the news because
you're everyone is just so quick to
judge and like in this instance that
headline is terrible like she didn't
show up to court there's a warrant for
her arrest but like to find out the
truth of what happened the incompetence
like it's so sad and the fact that she's
just at home and her apartment like was
waiting to be told what to do and right
oh one's telling her no totally but
that's also like you're a grown woman
get a real lawyer I'm sorry a lawyer
that doesn't check to see if your
postponement was approved like I don't
know what goes into being a lawyer but I
feel like that's an obvious thing to do
yes definitely I think but I feel like
in her hiring that lawyer like she
wasn't taking the situation seriously
perhaps I mean I mean II know yes I
agree I would like to know more about
the lawyer and like but it sounds like
it was really his fault you know you put
your hand you you trust you trust the
people that you're paying yeah a lot of
money to those really makes you shine
etcetera word and I was later and then
Shannon helped yeah I don't know and the
fact that that Boyer was able to call
off the sheriff's oh my god as they were
literally on their way to her house oh
my god that would have been horrible
hard well you know that she wouldn't
fill me or something so I BEC yeah no
but she does it the punishment doesn't
fit the crime
I agree you know um to bring our Kelty
I'm ready yeah I'm ready I'm ready for
sure but not if I didn't let you know
that the final sponsor of today's
episode is firstly saving money on
award-winning wine while you're
guaranteed to love has never been easier
than with firstly unlike other wine
clubs that guests about your favorite
wines firstly if uses your feedback and
ratings to curate wine selections
personalized to unique your unique
tastes first leaf is so confident in the
quality of their wine that they even
have a 100% satisfaction guarantee that
means if you're not feeling a particular
bottle of wine for a safe we'll cover it
completely you get started by taking the
first leave quiz online which is exactly
what we did and we have a bunch of
bottles that literally just arrived we
look at them all the time these beauties
they can assess your wine drinking
preferences from sweetness to wine
styles to even how adventurous you are
they learned a lot about what we like
when we took the quiz firstly then
created an introductory 6-pack of wine
for us all for 2995
seriously six packs of wine for
literally less than $30 less than wines
normally go for
these wines normally go for at least $20
bottle when our bottles arrived we
tasted and rated them and then oh that's
the best part it's like you can rate the
bottle online so that the next person
who comes and gets it like you can it
really is helpful in customer
satisfaction firstly sends out more than
17 thousand unique shipments of wine
every month because everyone's tastes
are different try the first sleeve wine
club today we're buying great wine is
simple sign up with our link and you'll
get an exclusive intro offer six bottles
of wine for only $29.99 plus free
shipping go to try first leaf dot-com /
toast that six bottles of wine for only
29.95 plus free shipping at try first
leaf calm / toast
sign on get drunk sign on get drunk
anywhere you want in the home beautiful
wines beautiful life if you have a
question for Kelty feel free to drop it
on the Instagram post about her or on
the YouTube feed if you're watching live
tons of questions for her I can't leave
shoes on the bachelor let's get her out
here we'll be back in five minutes go
get a sack we'll go to the bathroom
pluck your eyebrows see you then
you
welcome back to the morning toast we are
honored humbled and blessed to be
sitting here with our dead former rocket
host of the leading podcast host of the
lady Ching TV show host of Entertainment
Tonight and I just found out that you
were on The Bachelor you didn't know
that no Oh everyone's been on the ballot
season where you want okay so it's such
a long story I only lasted one day okay
so it was Brad Womack season number two
okay that's a great year Emily Maynard
yeah I know and you don't remember me
cuz it was only there for like one night
but what had happened was I'd had this
bad breakup my friend and I signed up at
the coffee shop at the 101 cafe and then
you kind of like start going through the
process and you're like wait someone's
picking me and when you have a broken
heart all you want is like to be cheated
by someone and you're like the casting
people think I'm so it and I remember
like well I had an agent at the time to
who was like you know if you want to be
a host in LA you should go on The
Bachelor and I was like okay so anyway
but the only thing that I find so funny
about is first of all I walked out of
the car and I remember being like I'm
not sure about this guy like are you a
nice person right I'm not sure so that
was number one then number two is like
then I couldn't believe how heartbroken
I was after 24 hours to get kicked off I
was like I'm never gonna find love and
this world like the way it is I hear my
phone away and like you can't have a
book you kind of a journal like I was
like oh my god I'm crushed and then I
got back in the real world and I was
like what I'm such a loser but anyway of
course I went on before you could get an
Instagram wait you should be at a
million site because I've been freaking
selling Tommy T and yeah I'm not working
so hard and I'm obsessed down you work
towards it I feel like you're so
successful I feel like it's crazy that
you're technically a part of bachelor
nation like I mean you'd go on bachelor
in paradise
you could lose you're married but you
couldn't but you could I think they have
to invite you and like they absolutely
like are not inviting me and you know
what I think
I have to tell you something I don't
know if it was him that wanted me off or
the producers but at the time of my life
I was sober and so I was not drinking
they don't like that and I think they
could tell that I wasn't drinking and
they were like get rid of this one yeah
they that for sure but allegedly I was
and it wasn't even that I was sober it
was that I was like having like a real
health kick I was like choosing the time
to like not eat blue right and also not
a drink at work on yourself yeah and
then also they freaking lied because I
remember I remember being on this health
kick and being like but there's some
wear to work out right and they're like
yes there's a gym no no there's not a
gym there's two yoga mats and an ab
roller well in the courtyard by the pool
yeah and they don't let you work out
they don't let anything that stimulates
your brain because they want you to go
crazy but it sounds like you were you
were too healthy to go crazy that's why
they catch you up at that moment
Yaba Blay that is so funny in fact was I
did a high ruckette kick out of the limo
gonca gun gun gun gun good guy I think
he would have been so good on it I would
have been amazing but they [ __ ] up I
should do you have on iTunes stars um
yeah we're not explicit yet no animation
we should be are we gonna talk about
other podcast buying ratings have you
guys okay done a deep dive no diverse
nobody makes me talk about I know I was
like I cannot wait to see the girls and
like I can't believe I'm here no I'm
like I just wanna like chat yeah well we
have all the time in the world please
tell us about the the I've heard i heart
radio podcasts like I Heart Radio
corporate like does that okay I didn't
know you can and like now where could
you do it and I don't know how all right
I know that expensive so Jack in the
lady gang is like investigator reported
she loves murder and she loves crime so
she started texting me and she was like
there's a podcast called crime junkie
crime junkies for the plagiarism yes so
they were plagiarizing but then on all
these subreddits
there was all this stuff about how like
they went from having 600 reviews to
like over 60,000 to over a hundred
thousand in the span of like two months
now as longtime podcasters we know even
with millions and millions of fan of the
TV show and the crazy downloads like
people just don't write
no they don't like them a matter of
reviews you have is never like a
reflective of your listenership like
it's it's annoying I would I've never
written a review for anything in my life
right exactly right well and I wrote one
for my own community yes I joined all
the time but it's just like it's kind of
wacky to think you have a show that has
like a hundred thousand reviews and all
the reviews are like so similar like
they're very body oh yeah it's like this
is my favorite podcast smiley face great
content smiley face and you're like no
one writes a review like that so that's
so then I got deep into it and started
looking and it's like it's just bananas
but then if you go on the top podcast
charts they're like in the top 200
episodes they have like 75 episodes in
the top 200 because the reviews he's
bumping they change the algorithm the
algorithm is we messed it has nothing to
do with people listening it has to do
with subscribe like ratings and well
okay so my husband's in the music
business I'm told me how it works
please so but I don't know if this is
like real or if he's just like full of
crap I love you but okay so allegedly
there's um an algorithm mix between
reviews new listeners and total
listeners so that's why shows like ours
like kind of hang out around 175 176 on
the top 200 even though we were playing
the pop most popular female it's the
same audience but it's because aren't
the toasters and the lady gang fans they
come every week and it's like the same
people and yes you get a couple new
people but that's why like when you know
whoever launches their new podcasts
they're like I'm number two but later
and she is number two she was number two
in TV and film she wants about to meet
up Cheryl right overall yeah but then
you look at the numbers no offense and
you're like oh about like thirty
thousand downloads that does it cuz
we've been launching all these shows to
the late again network and we're like
yeah you're number six then we and then
we're like expecting this big number and
we're like you got eleven thousand down
low excellent job so the algorithm is
messed up and I have learned I gotta let
it go
yeah cuz I'm a three on the intagram and
I am all about the like free money I
think you are where you care what people
think about you yeah the three the
achiever yeah the achiever like a little
annoying
yes
Jackie's a 1 I am a wife yeah like
perfectionist annoying I know that suits
you though yeah like I don't feel like
I'm a perfectionist but maybe that's the
perfectionist in me toting that it's not
enough you know rhyme we got so many
questions for you and obviously the one
that people want to know most is lady
gang season 2
do you have any intel we are working on
ideas that's exciting
oh yeah was it so much fun comes in your
house yeah well I had like a mental
breakdown in the middle of that that
whole Josh so it wasn't that fun for me
but as we say as an audience it was so
enjoyable to watch like it really and
we're so hard on can't we think digital
who transcend to traditional media
because they do a bad job then they ruin
it for us and give us a bad rep you did
I ever tell you or like I think I hate
maybe DM do you the story about when the
president of II brought note a morning
toast this is an amazing story so is
having breakfast with I'm gonna say the
run title but I believe it's president
of II Adam and he was like you know all
the young people in my office watch the
morning toast and they had this amazing
review of why they thought your show was
great versus other digital to TV shows
right and then we watched the whole
thing like the 15 minutes where you were
talking about it and that was like the
nicest thing well because it was really
good thank you
yeah it was really hard I think that the
hard thing about TV is that it's so
small and I think that people only got
to see one side of us which was like
that loud abrasive dick picks on yeah
and I think with podcast like you know
there's things like there's times where
I'll come in and I'll be like I'm a
horrible person and here's why and you
get to see like the soul of it and in TV
I don't think we really mastered that so
we're kind of trying to rejigger right
so that you know because women are a 360
humans and just yeah and like I think
what makes our brand cool is that we are
like kind of outspoken and like we'll
talk about anything but then to have
just like an entire season of like
tampon stories it was like what
aggressive and yet I get that
so we're trying to better ourselves and
so we're working on it we're gonna see
like if if it can go TVs very very
difficult
what was it like having all those people
in your house it was horrendous really
it's nice not to have to leave your
house that's true
yes well the number one joke of lady
game TV and everyone knows that is that
when you when you work on something and
you have a conglomerate of like 50
people working on it you don't always
get your way
no and being a three is either my way is
the only way I mean it is and my opinion
is the only one that matters you know
your opinion or your weight you know
that it's the right one
right so then the set designer like
picked this wallpaper that I I like kind
of visceral like päivi reactions would
you have had that reaction if it wasn't
your house yes Oh 100% but then it was
they put it up on my walls right it was
there from I think September until May
because we took a break between like the
first part in the second part and then
my husband and I lived with the set and
like over Christmas I didn't have a
Christmas tree it was just the washer
Winona and every time I came to Nestor
to make coffee it was just and I'm
getting yeah I've yeah um so really like
I loved lady getting TV the only thing
that I didn't like about it was the
wallpaper and I feel like it could have
been a different show had we had like a
different paper season too
if it becomes Swiss will you be in your
house I don't think so I think that's
probably good it was hard on my marriage
yeah it was hard we were living on a
cardboard Flo you know and but it was
like nice and like let's be honest like
I'm a hustler so like they obviously
paid me to use the space Oh should I
want these Louboutins with that money
I'm fine
Oh with that is always every time I was
like oh it's just so hard she's like
they're paying you alright okay and your
home is also in renovations because you
are like Joanna Gaines like renovating
bathrooms
yes well I'm almost done we bought a
fixer-upper three years ago and I've
been fixing it up and I like to do the
things myself oh so I've been hanging
things and sanding things and just we're
about to start the backyard which I
think will be dirty red fun and like you
know it's it's kind of sad that I'm like
here's me with Britney Spears and here's
me with JLo and people are like but what
about your backyard la like what toilet
paper roll are we hanging today and I
was like that's cool though if I can
help the people well you have so many
jobs and one of your most interesting
ones is being a host of Entertainment
Tonight you get to do every red carpet
you
believe what I have on the show tonight
this is live live right yeah this is not
tonight I got the only interview that's
ever happened with Britney Spears's
boyfriend semester I saw that on your
Instagram yes why I want it it's like
life changing was she there she wasn't
there um but I've seen him on carpets
with her and I fought obviously followed
their love on Instagram and he just has
such a mean face yeah he does he looks
consistently angry and I was like wow
this guy has got to be a real jerk and
then he came in and he was like hey is
so nice to meet you like so
down-to-earth like almost two
down-to-earth I was like are you con man
but the nicest guy and he was like my
family's from I run like they're all
back there like they come once a year
like I just he's very like almost three
ish like yeah like I work out and I have
lists and like whatever and they was
talking about the boys and like the
family and like he talked about Brittany
like she was just like a regular girl
and he was like no we just love to watch
movies and like well I love it when she
does the fashion shows because like
she's I'm taping it like I was like who
takes her workout videos who decides the
workout he's like really honestly like
yes I work out but Brittany's been
dancing like her whole life she just
loves it so you can't stop her and I was
just like oh my god you're like talking
about Britney Spears away my husband
talks about me it is like I think it's
gonna change the journal is a vulture I
mean this could be my next I mean this
could be it oh yes you have an Emmy yeah
Entertainment Tonight won best oh my god
I'm so embarrassed I'm not gonna know
Entertainment News
it's a Daytime Emmy it's not a night
time I mean so does it matter
it doesn't say did you go to the awards
yes was it inquiry boring it was long
yes you know what's Daytime Emmys it's
like all the soap opera stars and if you
don't watch soap operas
cuz I have a job yeah that takes a long
time and then it's like dr. Phil
whatever but it's always fun and it's
just funny because I've been nominated
this is those my fourth nominee
nomination so I've been nominated and
lost three times and I like my outfits
got less special as time because the
first time I nominate I'm like yellow
bow he
look you know and then like as time went
on and then the year you won what did
you wear um oh my god oh I had just had
a car accident
Oh and I was in a cast and I had a Saint
Laurent like one-shoulder fringe dress
that was fabulous but like it's black
which is a color I don't ever wear
really I'm well this is navy blue yeah
it's dark but like black on the red
carpet is a big if you're a thirsty
[ __ ] like me yeah yeah I want the press
you don't wear black Oh black is for
like Kate Moss Kate Moss gets our
picture they'll take your picture if
you're Kate Moss if I walk down a red
carpet and something black all the
cameras just go down cuz they're like
magazine maybe that's our problem they
don't buy they don't buy black pictures
interests it's my number one thing when
people like how do I get famous I'm like
we're on the red carpet
wow that's gonna be so tough amazing is
how I only wear black and all I want to
do is be famous so I'll have to figure
that out you're gonna have to start any
honestly silver and metallics don't work
either oh gotta be in yellow it's got to
be like color of the season Amerigo
right right know what I mean yeah you
look at the vogue and then you're like
oh everyone's wearing seafoam I'll wear
seafoam and even if you don't feel your
best
it doesn't matter I'll feel your best
when you're not sweet Leigh that is such
a good advice your well truly and the
thing I mean literally needed to talk to
you about that I'm so glad I didn't
forget is you had a crazy week because
you were on Liz's Instagram yeah okay
and it's the funniest video ever we were
so excited when we saw it yeah we're
like we have to so she tells you about
this so you guys know that I have like
now a history of making a fool of myself
on other people's like instagrams yes
hice so before Liz oh I do want I'll
tell you about it so I've met the Met
Gala and Tiffany Haddish is there and
ice and kris Jenner's behind her so I'm
like it's like very competitive a gala
to get the interviews because there's no
publicist there's no like can you bring
your client over it's like come over to
me you know I'm with Tiffany Haddish and
I see Kris Jenner I'm like I cannot miss
Chris Jent oh that's a big moment you
know so I'm like oh Tiffany guess who
else is there
guess who's ready Kris Jenner she ready
and then I was like oh is that like
appropriation if I say she ready like
I'm not sure so then I said she is ready
Oh like I put it in English and then the
internet was like oh it was so fun so
bad so then the internet decided like I
was a horrible person and then just kept
playing that on a repeat and then lizzo
interview happened this week of course
and I'm like we did this whole beautiful
interview oh my god you were gonna quit
oh my god took 12 years to become an
overnight sensation oh my god Bosley
positivity like so many beautiful topics
and she was so awesome and she hadn't
slept after the VMAs and it was like a
great interview and then we do a speed
round and the speed round is like if you
weren't 100% that [ __ ] what would your
DNA say and just goes I'm black Jericho
like oh it's fine we're never gonna air
it like it's not gonna go out in the
world cuz it like I was like okay
question and my face is kind of like
boom and then of course somewhere on the
internet it went out and then they snip
that little piece and then I get all
these mean messages that are like you
need better questions
oh my god interviewer and then all I do
is I just Ted I like click the copy
paste my entire like 11 minute interview
that's online I'm like here's mammy
here's my wait I'm like of course but
people don't understand they get so mad
when they're like how dare you ask a
woman which is wearing on the red carpet
and I was like let me tell you something
I'm from sure Park Alberta Canada what
people wear on the red carpet is
important it's my life yeah it's my
escape from the cows red and school and
all the other things like people don't
act like you don't you didn't get
dressed up no totally that's like it's
it's supposed to be fun entertainment is
hope in New York Times right right
totally you know and one day I will be
the New York Times right and then I'll
sit down and be like let's talk about
the effect of climate change on your
movie but for now right I'm on
Entertainment Tonight I'm entertaining
it and maybe then you'll get nominated
or win a People's Choice Award whoa oh
yeah he just told us that the People's
Choice Awards nominations came out and
we didn't even know obviously because uh
we were nominated and Lady Anne was
nominated last year
and lost not nominated this year how
does it feel - losers two years in a row
so we didn't even up for it right
we're cool enough to be a loser right
well I mean I want to be happy for my
friends that are nominated good job
Caitlyn good job scrubbing in yes I I
think that Dax Shepard nominations a
little bit of a racket celebrity
I agree we're gonna need to split the
categories now it's gonna be celebrity
podcast and regular hustling podcast
podcast like you know what Amy did you
see Conan O'Brien on the cover of
variety saying he was the king of
podcasts and he's changing the medium
and bringing it to a mainstream audience
hurtful hurtful but it's like it's so
much easier to book celebrities and have
a great show of when you're a celebrity
right Conan O'Brien has no trouble
booking guests on his show do you know
what I mean yeah well actually he kind
of does does he's not as cute cool as he
used to be I don't think he's ever
really liked yeah okay but anyway my
point being is like I am I was honored
to be nominated and they can never take
it away Never Knows choice loser is very
good on my brand and you guys look so
cute on the red carpet with your
matching pastels it's gonna be sad to be
out stood this year well you can hang
out with us I think they need more than
one podcast category because podcasts
are huge so just hop culture podcast
like what about comedy write about
crying I know at least celebrity and
regular right and the webbie's you know
they had a podcast category and we
submitted ourselves and it cost like
thousands of dollars to submit yourself
right and I was like to win what a webby
I know what you mean like I just I'm
like whatever
anyway the People's Choice Award I'm I'm
more mad for you guys so our way you
know what I mean because we've had our
time in the spotlight to lose but what
the hell is our chance to lose you're a
conglomerate business of podcasting
every freaking day we shoot ourselves in
the foot because we want the respect of
E but we're over here like making fun of
them all the time look this way they're
not gonna throw us a bone like we
literally talk so much [ __ ] about that
we do but we also like source them all
the time like three stories that we're
driving traffic we are you are I think
it's you know I like to say this I think
that we're so busy hustling
we didn't have time to ssin angle
ourselves into the nominations too busy
creating excellent content and you know
what I hate traveling to LA anyway so
know you love it and you would have worn
black and I would have been wondering
why our photos weren't up well yes I
want is honestly we don't we don't have
like the success to do it but I would
like you guys to make like the the
morning toast Awards like we'd like to
tell the choices we've spoken about no I
know because the revolve Awards like you
know how the revolve clothing company
has awards and anybody winter of the air
all their friends and they're like House
of the Year model of the year total well
if you guys started the awards you could
just call your friends and be like you
get best trio podcast of the year lady
gang did your best do oh yes I like that
right you what you would get the like
the icon award
yeah and Jackson Joan Rivers Award for
Excellence yeah yeah create the award
show you wish to see in the world you
know what I mean I don't know I will say
that I was really hard on winning an
Emmy and I was like I gotta win an Emmy
I gotta win an Emmy and then now it's
like in my living room and I don't care
actually really you stop caring what I
want is like a really great clutch like
that I like literally while I was
waiting in your green room I was like
hmm should I work should I go in the
real real and try to find an expensive
club you should you should you have one
in mind it's hard to find a good cause
cheese days I know it's not easy Parker
I want that like claw Bottega yes with
the knitted yeah that's a good one
can I take some questions from Instagram
oh my god joy BK craziest red carpet
moment you've ever witnessed Jake
Gyllenhaal I told him he was sexy he
walked away stop up since Jordan Tomas I
feel like you're always on the go how do
you balance work social and personal
life I don't usually I like cry in a
corner i emotionally eat like carbs late
at night and then like hate myself later
okay that's relatable
yeah she'll Stevens 11 can you tell us a
little bit about bout your Rockette days
you have hilarious stories and it was
just how much it was a staple in your
childhood well the greatest thing about
being a Rockette was
my vagina was too big for the bodysuits
this is my claim to fame
I was rockin for six seasons and I was a
dancer every year ever since now this
kids a really spectacular me look like
outfits like pictures of us in Rockette
costumes like the green long-sleeved
dress like when we were six okay yeah
yeah dude John has sown on the show once
we're like we scan okay okay yeah we
respect the hell out institution it's
the institution it's so glamorous
immediately and I've never been treated
better at a job it was at the Rockettes
they treat the Rockettes like your
goddamn princesses vagina
oh yes the big vagina so I do not have
breasts but I think what God when God
was making me they're like we still want
to give you cleavage and they gave me
like a vagina lip cleavage my husband is
like please stop talking about this cuz
it's not that big but for me it is and
so there's like all the corsets and body
suits you wear and basically they're
like quite thin you know like a Sophia
Ricci bikini right you know I mean for a
little peep you prepubescent vagina my
vagina's a full lady and so I have to go
into the fittings and they would like
have to add like extra fabric around the
side like a maxi pad with wings to like
make sure because when you're kicking
right and you're splitting that is when
it can open yeah yeah well you all
experienced a front wedgie on your
vagina so like when you're doing 90
minutes of kicks all of a sudden it's a
front thumb well and so I had a bigger
vagina but also the great thing is that
while I was in those costume fittings I
made them put boob pads in every one of
my costumes I saw no boobs especially
during the radius it's easy you lose so
much weight cuz you're bright enough so
much so like everyone is like so much
chested and then I would have like these
huge like beautiful breasts in all of my
leg because I was like can you double up
the boob pads and they could I'd be like
it's Christmas one time oh my god it was
such a good story one time I was about
you know the bus scene yes of course
okay so the bus scene happens
so the everyone in the New York City
scene is dancing and the
cats come in down in it and we all strut
into like a thing yep double-decker yep
and then and then we walk around and
then we get on the bus and then they go
for the bus ride so we have these white
coats and then these jackets and the hat
and earrings and it's a very quick
change you finish the soldiers and
you're like you know get change you give
like 35 seconds to change and so I'm
standing backstage and I'm like getting
ready to step on the stage no panties I
only had the tight I forgot a very
important step with my costume change
dress earrings gloves hat Jacket shoe
change so when you catch a leg up no I
couldn't go onstage there's no pants oh
you do that with ruined Christmas
and I was like ah and then I ran back
around and was like and it was like such
a weird thing because you're so used to
your track of like where I go and I had
to find my white underwear and I put
them on and then I joined in and like
[ __ ] come bus oh my god right that's
the last year they ever hired me yeah
there's no from the station the
Rockettes it is a serious absolutely not
forgetting your panties is like our
babies and that's like the worst thing
you could've done yeah yeah this isn't a
question from Instagram but is just a
question for me because you hosts late
again with Becca Tobin and I am myself
like a rather large Gleek and I want to
know if you've ever watched Glee like
before you knew Becca yes well when Glee
was on I did not have the money for a
television okay it was the struggle bus
year her label I was a professional
dancer during the time and I auditioned
quite often to be a dancer on Glee on
success oh wow yes I had a pair of
Walmart stretch skinny jeans that were
purple
I'd wear my purple stretch jeans with
combat boot and a denim vest but that's
berry bleeped Oakley I know and you
didn't get it never got it so but I
remember Becca getting Glee because we
have all these mutual friends and
everyone was like Becca's quitting
Broadway she's gonna go do spray tans in
San Francisco or something you can ask
her about it when she comes on the show
oh yeah she's coming Friday I think
she's coming
baby's coming Friday anyway so she went
to go juice she was quitting dancing to
be spray tanner and then the next thing
I know she was on Glee and I was on and
then I had switched over my job and
select last two years I was working as a
baby cub reporter at insider and I'd see
on the red carpet I was like wow those
are the days you're so
that's like $65 a week yeah
I'm sweet and sulky what is the best
career advice I've ever gotten the best
career advice is I think just stop
saying just that is such good advice any
email any phone call any text like just
checking in just wanted to see if you
received my resume
just be like following up getting more
direct and I also think that I have just
been through this personally you have to
sit down and realize your Worth and when
it comes to getting the job or
negotiating the job that the whole
business of business is to make you feel
like you're not worth it hmm you know
and I do this with our podcast and and
everything in life women we just
apologize for taking up space so much
and I've learned especially in last year
to just be like you know what I have a
talent even though my talent is like
it's a talent um I can host live
television for 4 or 5 hours at a time
like I'm a hard worker I'm always
responsible to show up on time like
there's so many things that you kind of
blow away and I'm like you know what I'm
worth it and I am NOT going to accept
less than i realistically deserve to do
this because or else my life is a
disaster right because there was a time
where like I was saying during lady gank
TV like I was doing et full time I was
using vacation days to shoot eat lady
game TV on Tuesdays and then running to
shoots at night still a little bit drunk
for me it was like not it was just such
a crazy time and we were also writing
our book it was just so much going on
I'm still recording the podcast we still
do any odd cast launching the network
like I mean there was just so much going
on and I was like why did I set my life
up like this like I'm taking pennies
from everyone to make a dollar when if I
asked for what I deserved in every area
of my life and then made my hate to like
quote Katy Perry and her documentary
like relationship day is a priority but
then I think I'll have a better so I'm
like four days into my new life and I
think so far looks like refresh yeah
yeah a good time no it's because I'm
also the supermodel diet oh what's that
okay so every year around this time the
Victoria's Secret Angels are usually
getting ready not this year not this
year it's canceled but I have a couple
friends in as the Angels which makes you
sound like douchebag I really just have
one but um anyway so they always do the
Train like an angel and then I would be
around her and I'd see what she eats and
she would just eat like protein of
vegetables which is essentially a carb
free diet weight so I am going to the
Seychelles with my husband to renew our
vows at Christmas that is beautiful I
have like a lot of body goes like I have
a beautiful body and I love myself so
much but like I want to be [ __ ] like
sorry Cherie that's like a behind
picture of me on the beach where my butt
is like apples right and it's not there
yet like I am I am right now feeling
great feeling great and close okay
nakedness no it's not there yet I don't
know how to ever be there right so I'm
like I'm doing like yesterday I went for
sushi with my husband and I like just
ate sushi me know right salad and I took
out the rice I tried a sushi that it was
wrapped in cucumber it tastes like skin
it's just that's a thing and I love
cucumber no thing but not in the sea
it's the weirdest thing now my final
question for you is just out of genuine
curiosity how long have you been doing
lady game podcasts um I think the
podcast is four years old Wow yeah and
how do you know the lady game girls oh
this is so great great question thank
you you should get an Emmy they at least
a People's Choice or so Becca and I used
to run in the dancer circle together in
New York City and she had a blog and I
was like in the internet world and so we
knew each other through that Jack and I
dated the same dude someone we know he
was um I know the Internet's not gonna
be like why do you keep talking about
this and talking about it because she
was a your ad were connected and anyone
else so we're over it but like it's how
we're connected how you dicks it was the
old guitars for Panic at the Disco
lagging in midday Wow grouping yeah that
must have been fun day what I mean I was
Jack was there before the real band
really was big but like I was there
during like the closing of the goddamn
door and we were like in
Harris bowling very edgy and I think I
fell in love with that yeah and like
didn't have my blinders on to be like is
this person a good person right but is
it my lifestyle but it was like oh I'm
on a tour bus and friends that is great
it was sick so anyway we met through
that and so then when we back in I had
this idea to start the show I was like I
know this girl is so cool it's inviter
and then I invited invited Jack and now
you know the podcast and we I want you
to network you guys have a network so we
just follow up me just kind of watch
whatever you guys do and then we do it
like you got merch we got merged you
just say like when we wanted to start a
network we told our team we're like the
way the lady gang does it yeah yeah we
were first you have to give credit where
credit is due
you were fresh but you have shows now
and you're not right it's great it's all
right a network boss yeah what bosses am
i no I am the boss of people and it's so
great because I love to boss Jim that's
the three is so great because you can
put it on your feet and then it has a
big launch right away and it's like it's
the power it's like it's rising tides
chips so true um we I want to ask you
something you guys have do you do box
yet no do you do the box boxes on our
boxes on sale right now and it's really
good and you would you do what yeah but
tell us tell us about the box
okay well the box is monthly
subscription it's no I'd say it's a
one-time-only you can buy it every
quarter and like this this time we have
like that Chi fragrance and so the
fragrance is like 60 bucks but the box
is only 50 I like pie a hair stuff we
let go to all the brands that we like
right we've like Spencer pressed
crystals like way it's judgy but I if
you I think you should yeah like a gif
you should do one for Christmas make a
beard thing then ask your people like
what going to seat it and use your power
and go out and get those brownies and
snacks in the box
no can't
no because that's the mistake we made we
did you you can't have something so
heavy
okay oh wait [ __ ]
shibi shipping's like $45 in the box
something like you're only charging
people ten bucks and then you all the
money oh [ __ ]
like right now our box has this big
thing of tumor cuz I love like a you
know golden latte it's so good for you
gin in your skin and we put it in and
like everyone's getting their box and
they're like my tumeric is like some
like you know people put the knife in to
open the box and break and then it's
like that is hilarious we also put a
vibrator in our last box
oh very scary you can have a vibrator
yeah why'd you point to me cuz you're
the three she looks like she might be
she definitely liked it doesn't not yet
it was knows what about she doesn't ever
seen ya outfit to me says anal fingers
only
you know this says to me lengthy I don't
like a full lace she puts the lady and
lady gang oh yeah like you to me are
like rock on one in the bum I think
that's a great way that everyone follow
oh by the way you have at Kelty on
instagram which is like the most
probably the most your biggest
achievement yes yeah it's really
impressive and Becca has a Becca
yeah Becca helped me and get at County
yeah I feel like I've BEC is a little
bit hard to forget cuz it's more to come
there's human even Becca's right and
there's a row Becca's you had a counter
wallet my friend is shaking yeah yeah
back all the Becca's from The Bachelor
follow her on Instagram listen to lady
gang entertainment tonight with Sam
asghari red a night that's gonna be
really [ __ ] exciting this was so much
fun thank you for being here me also
having Becca Tobin on Friday I think
that's gonna work out right it was done
it is working out package opens coming
on Friday
Louis Vuitton bags yes we have magic
dick love you guys have a great day
thank you for tuning into the morning
chest and Lenny Oh morning Shelby go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so feel free to
subscribe this video a thumbs up we're
also available anywhere podcast can be
found set Spotify iTunes stitcher Public
Radio literally everywhere I don't know
where people listen to podcasts leave
this five star review about like how
we're so beautiful is getting recognized
smart educated yeah like really
well-rounded yeah thank you guys we'll
see you tomorrow
you